Welcome back. I hope that exercise went great.
Now, let's talk about another important Datastore concept,
keys. When you store an entity in the
Datastore, the Datastore will assign a key to
it. This key uniquely identifies the entity and
it's used for many different purposes. They are
two ways a key can be generated. Let's take a look. The first one is when
Datastore automatically generates this key. Let's say we
define the profile kind with these properties. And inserted
it for the first time. In this case, the
Datastore will automatically assign a key value to it.
The other way is that you specify what is called a key name or ID. In this case,
Datastore will use that value to generate the key.
This is a good alternative when you have something
that is unique for each entity. Because it can clearly
take us to our front entity based on this value
so it's easier to find. But observe that statement. The
Keyname/ID must be unique for all entities of that kind. For
our profile kind that is exactly the case because we
have decided to use the user ID to to uniquely
identify each profile identity. The value of having user ID
as the key name is that we can retrieve the profile
entity directly using this value. And remember, since the
user object is the first parameter to cloud endpoints API
methods. It will become a convenient way to get
the profile, but we'll look more into this later. If
you are familiar with relational database modeling, you probably
see that this is very similar to the concept of
a primary key. There, as well as with Datastore,
you have the option of letting the database generate the
primary key or use the value of your choice.
But now, it's for you to do some work